pour madame monsieur bonjour l'invité de
sao qu'a dit ce matin sylvia sa soutane
bonjour vous êtes donc conseillère
exécutive à la ctm chargé de l'éducation
entre autres
enfin s'il versailles soutane enfin les
élus tous bords confondus se mobilisent
contre la violence la manifestation a eu
lieu devant le commissariat du lamentin
vendredi dernier et vous y étiez oui
tout à fait je pense que c'est important
de que nous y soyons d'abord pour
montrer un signal fort qu en martinique
la violente ça suffit aussi bien la
violence avec les armes dont on a parlé
les policiers qui sont tous les jours un
sujet assez c'est problème là les
violences faites aux femmes également
qui me tiennent à coeur est tout sauf ce
climat de violence je pense qu'il faut
que ça cesse et je crois qu'on est des
élus les élus sont là aussi pour alerter
pour être des personnes qui sonne un
petit peu et qui disent qu'il faut que
les choses avancent mais bon j'ai envie
de me croire et qu'on pourra avec toutes
les énergies positives passer à autre
chose
il a fallu quand même attendre seize
morts par armes à feu pour une
implication des élus ce que nos élus
martiniquais ont dit visière alors moi
je ne suis pas complètement d'accord
avec cette vision là c'est vrai que le
point d'ordre a été fait vendredi
mais moi depuis que je suis en politique
je fais je fais justement ce travail
contre la violence je le fais en
essayant d'abord tout d'abord en tant
que politique de garder une ligne calme
une ligne stable une ligne qui montrent
que je ne suis pas une élue violentes et
je crois que ça c'est important
également dans le domaine de l'éducation
j'ai tragique oeuvré en tant que
qu'enseignante mais également en tant
que politique pour apaiser les choses et
faire en sorte que la violence n'existe
pas donc je pense que les élus et
monsieur david zobda l'a très bien dit
ce sont des élus qui travaillent au
quotidien sur l'avion surtout les élus
de terrain que sont les maires souvent
ce sens qu'ils sont confrontés à toutes
les problématiques qu'on rencontre sur
un petit territoire et il sent il
s'engage aujourd'hui les députés se sont
engagés j'en suis très heureuse député
de martinique
ils sont sept martinique guadeloupe ils
ne sont que celles sur les les huit qui
aurait pu être présents en cas ça ça
avance mais c'est à dire que c'est je
pense que ça les urgences qui font qu'on
a l'impression que les élus ne font rien
ou que non je pense qu'il travaille
énormément sur ça alors vous l'avez dit
une lettre des parlementaires une moue
lisa sion des élus et un silence
assourdissant du gouvernement
c'est ce qui me fait de la peine
quelques mois j'ai toujours revendiqué
le fait qu' on est on avait le droit en
tant que français d'avoir les mêmes
droits et aujourd'hui parfois je me pose
la question je me dis est ce que c'est
parce que nous sommes à 7000 kilomètres
qu'on ne prend pas assez en compte nos
réalités et je parle de ce que je
connais la violence en a parlé monsieur
louis liberté en a parlé lors de la
dernière intervention beaucoup de morts
à marseille on mobilise des personnes du
personnel à marseille actuellement la
technique on en glisse pas voilà c'est
ça le mépris que ce qui se passe alors
je pense pas que ce soit les prix je
pense que l'oreille l'oreille attentive
du gouvernement n'est peut-être pas en
temps encore assez explicite pour la
martinique
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que nos
élus à mon avis ne sont pas suffisamment
tendue alors il aurait fallu un élu en
marche qui est l'oreille du président
j'espère que le monsieur le président ne
travaille pas comme ça et j'espère qu'il
est allé coûte de coucy spa j'ai vu qu
avait des journalistes de de freud de
france france info qui étaient présents
donc j'espère que ce sera relayée et
j'espère que notre président pqi et ne
présente de tout le monde a aujourd'hui
qui a été voté à l'unanimité et coûtera
y entendra et ne laissera pas le fait
que les 7000 kilomètres nous séparent de
la france hexagonale mais comme la
guyane qu'on renvoie ça d'un revers de
main voyez avec la ministre d outre mer
ce que ce n'est pas ça veut dire que non
ça ne regarde pas le gouvernement dans
c'est un problème d outre-mer majuscule
c'est vrai je suis assez excédé de ça je
vous reconnais il ya une chose qui me
choque comme en france hexagonale c'est
que la guyane par exemple qui est un
territoire qui représente presque le
quart de la france sur toutes les cartes
qui sont présentés aux élèves elle est
considérée comme si c'était une île au
même titre que la martinique au niveau
de la superficie
quand la france comprendra que la
martinique la guadeloupe la guyane la
réunion sont de réels département de
réelles département je pense qu'on
avancera beaucoup mieux il faut faire
comme les frères en tout cas bien
regarder enfin je crois qu'il faut
surtout qu'on ait des élus qui qu'ils
soient capables de mobiliser
je pense l'église de bons sentiments qui
doivent diriger un gouvernement que son
avec d'un slogan quand même intéressant
liberté égalité
fraternité et j'oserais dire sororité
alors on poursuit notre notre notre
interview ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle votre opposition au sein de la
collectivité territoriale faisait hier
sa rentrée et les noms été incisif
immobilisme précarité exode des jeunes
dont il parizon quand on regarde la
martinique
et quand on écoute les chefs
d'entreprise notamment ceux du btp
alors non je ne pense pas que de lever
les uns contre les autres a jamais été
une solution
aujourd'hui je sais que la nouvelle là
monsieur le président d'ensemble
nouvelle députée ouvre aujourd'hui une
commission parlementaire sur le corps
déconne je rappelle je suis ça me fait
plaisir que j'en change un peu d'avis je
rappelle que quand je sais j'ai au
conseil général
nous étions deux seulement monsieur
charpentier ancien maire de basse pointe
et moi-même à s'être élevé contre 7,7
l'ancienne mandature du conseil général
donc été ensemble de martigues nouvelles
sur contre le fait que nous poursuivions
les plans d'angers rien nous étions les
seuls aujourd'hui je suis content que le
débat ait changé et qu'ils aient envie
de porter ces problèmes parce que gars
que les imbéciles qui ne changent pas
d'avis mais le clown mais pas eu
d'épandage avec le clown mais qu'importe
c'est quand même ces mêmes
problématiques
attention quand même les mêmes cibles et
matic c'est quand même ce que je veux
dire c'est une problématique mais par
contre ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'à
force d'accuser les autres de penser de
faire croire que nous ne bougeons pas de
faire croire que ça n'avance pas ça
rentre un peu dans la tête des gens et
moi c'est parce que je vis au quotidien
en tant qu'élu depuis quatre ans je
trouve que les choses avancent certes
pas assez vite peut-être pour certains
et certaines et à force de distiller ce
discours de violence justement on parle
de violence cette violence politique
n'est pas dans la construction alors se
sont pas tous les élus d'ensemble pour
une martinique nouvelle qui ont ce
discours là il y en a qui sont à mon
avis très constructif mais il y en a qu
à mon avis qu'ils perdent justement le
cap quand on est politique on doit
montrer l'exemple
on doit montrer le cap et quand on
montre un cap qui est tout le temps dans
la violence tout le temps dans la
déchirure et bien malheureusement on
n'arrive pas à passer par dessus
on connaît tous le proverbe quand le btp
va tout va malheureusement le btp ne va
pas en martinique alors là c'est pour
moi une grande
je suis un peu triste de cette situation
monsieur le président alfred marie
jeanne a toujours été quelqu'un qui
s'engageait auprès des btp et qui paient
rubis sur l'ongle toutes ses factures
aujourd'hui nous sommes parfois dans des
difficultés d'abord parce qu'on a des
entreprises qui n'ont pas forcément les
reins toujours très solide qui prennent
de gros chantiers qui prennent beaucoup
de chantiers qui n'ont pas de trésorerie
pour avancer à six mois avec une
visibilité mois et aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'on a des entreprises très en
difficulté parce qu'on a au niveau de la
collectivité territoriale de martigny
des situations qui sont que nous devons
payer ce qui a été engagé auparavant
aussi les délais de paiement exactement
il ça c'est quelque chose qui ne
ressemble pas au président de faire en
sorte que ces d être payé soit aussi
long mais moi je pense que c'est notre
combat à la collectivité territoriale de
martinique de régler cette situation ça
ne nous arrange pas ça ne nous arrange
pas parce que moi par exemple beaucoup
de chantiers dans les établissements
scolaires sont parfois bloquées parce
que les entreprises il va oui mais là au
bout d'un moment il faut qu'on puisse
payer nos âges nos envies nos ouvriers
nos ouvrière ici et je comprends ça donc
moi j'espère qu'on aura une année là
pour régler ça on puisse avancer de
manière solide
d'accord vous serez candidate je suppose
un 2021
pour les élections à la 7e vous allez
défendre le bilan d' alfred marie jeanne
je vais défendre le mien je vais
défendre celui des élus de bap et
anchamps c'est qu'ils nous avons
fonctionné avec alfred marie-jeanne
certaine
certaines choses ont été un partage et
d'autres pas et d'ailleurs nous en avons
fait la vision financière le fait que
par exemple nous puissions avoir un
emprunt beaucoup plus important que
celui était est et qui a été initiée par
exemple c'est vrai que moi je suis un
peu surprise d'avoir désengager la
collectivité de passer de 14 ans une
collectivité qui était endetté à 14 ans
passés à 8 ans c'est bien dans un sens
on pourrait dire que c'est bien sauf que
quelque part nous en faisons les frais
et aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que
c'était forcément le bon le bon système
dont il ya des choses que nous allons
défendre moi mon bilan je sais que je
travaille en d'incidents dans les
établissements scolaires le mieux que je
peux donc je ne peux que le défendre
parce que j'en suis fier et il ya des
choses sur lesquelles nous allons
revenir bien sûr ça veut dire que dans
les deux ans qui vous reste à peu près
environ 1 2 ans vous que vous allez 6 de
vous démarquer quand je dis vous un
public attendant vous madame sylvia sass
total mais le groupe que vous
représentez on le fait déjà
on le fait déjà à chaque plénière vous
l'avez j'ai remarqué dès l'intervention
de yann de diamant rose de karine
rousseau
ce sont les interventions qui sont très
fortes qui sont parfois pas super sympa
suffisamment relayée mais on remarque
souvent des points dans tout un tas
d'améliorations que nous pensons utile
et donc nous ne sommes pas des béni oui
oui nous sommes des gens qui travaillent
on qui avons des convictions il manque
toujours de millions au cnt par exemple
par exemple un parent exactement il y en
a des ja si vous voulez des choses vont
maintenant chaque camp quand j'entends
une mangue millions oui mais sauf qu'on
a aujourd'hui une collectivité qui doit
faire face à beaucoup d'obligations et
beaucoup de difficultés donc il faut
aussi garder raison on ne peut pas non
plus demander demandé demandé puis de ne
pas travailler mais on a à mon avis
beaucoup de marge d'amélioration et on
le fera savoir au moment venu
parlons des municipales vous n'êtes même
pas candidate aux municipales à rivière
salée
est ce que ce n'est pas une forme de
renoncement n'ont absolument pas je
pense que vous me connaissez bien
monsieur livrer les martiniquais et
martine cazes me connaissent je ne suis
pas une femme de renoncement je suis une
femme d'engagement et je suis une femme
aussi de conviction moi j'aime pas aller
aux élections j'ai déjà perdu les
élections une fois ou deux je n'aime pas
trop ça c'est pas une chose que j'aime
et d'autre part non pas que je vais
perdre avec monsieur andré lesueur mais
nous avons le même électorat
d'autre part je pense que son bilan est
élogieux je pense qu'il a travaillé les
salles et 1 est salée elle mesure à
travailler avec toute son équipe n'est
pas seul il l'a frappé avec tous ses
collègues du conseil municipal
il fait même unanimité avec les
oppositions qui travaillent qui votent à
l'unanimité ces décisions donc moi j'ai
dit quand ça fonctionne
allons continuer mais en même temps ce
que je dis c'est que nous avons des
convictions qui sont communes et je ne
me vois pas les contrôles monsieur andré
lesueur pour quelque prétexte que ce
soit tout à fait alors c'est ce qu'on
vous dit mais est-ce que vous allez le
soutenir d'or parce qu'il va peut-être
être candidat ce que vous allez le
soutenir mais regardez ce que j'ai à
dire aujourd'hui on va me va m'appeler à
regard salles aujourd'hui ma violence il
a bien su bien soutiennent des des
campagnes avec lui par exemple s'il me
demande si des choses qui sont
envisageables mais en tout cas ce que je
pourrais défendre c'est le bilan qu'il a
menées sur des actions auxquelles je
crois
par exemple je vois qu'on a une maison
des seniors à rivière-salée je suis pas
sûr qu'ils aient brut commune où il ya
des millions des seniors on a également
18 sur les huit écoles ça c'est un peu
moi je le dis mais qu'ils ont quittée
cole en a six qui ont été carrément soit
rénové soient reconstruites avec une qui
en passe d'être construite et l'autre
qu'il sera bientôt donc et un travail
qui est conséquent avec les associations
et est donc je pense qu'on a on la lit
là il a une belle une belle chose à
faire vous avez la même vision de la
droite que conduit le tueur alors les la
droite moi je ne suis pas très à droite
par exemple en martinique on a plusieurs
gauche on le voit pourtant ne parle pas
de la gauche
on parle des gauches on parle de gauche
que vous connaissez et en martinique je
pense qu'on a plusieurs droites en moi
la droite c'est le mot n'est pas le bon
pour moi ce que je crois c'est que je
crois fortement en l'économie pour moi à
une économie dans un pays c'est un
modèle de développement
quand on a trop de chômage en martinique
quand on a trop de d'entreprises en
difficulté on ne peut pas construire et
on a trop de personnes qui sont à
attendre malheureusement être attentiste
sur les ailes les aides de l'état et ça
je n'y crois pas c'est pour ça que je
suis voulait que jusqu'à dégrisé à
droite parce que je crois
fondamentalement au moteur clé
d'économies est ce que vous n'avez pas
plus une vision politique différente
quand vous qu'on vous fait une alliance
avec alfred marie-jeanne l'entrée le
cyan n'aurait peut-être pas fait cette
même année en smaïl à fait puisque
meygal laventure l'assigner meygal
l'aventuré le premier secrétaire de
forces martiniquaises de progrès pu
rentrer le surnom c'est en tout cas son
groupe c'est clairement mobiliser avec
nous oui on va te le dis c'est quand
même directement clairement son premier
secrétaire de monsieur laventure s'est
mobilisée directement vous savez ce que
je pense en martinique c'est ça que je
voulais dire aussi c'est que il faut pas
faire l'impasse il faut arrêter cette
violence justement peut-être qui est lié
de notre histoire j'ose espérer qu'on
arrivera un jour à la dépasser
mais cette violence qui fait qu'on se
monte les uns contre les autres on peut
travailler les uns avec les autres tout
en donnant nos points de divergence et
c'est d'ailleurs les points de
divergence et différences qui font qu'un
système avance quand on est tous
d'accord ben on est dans une autocratie
on est quand on se confronte dans ce
dieu être que je me jette hors peut-être
que cette manière là n'est pas la bonne
à ce qu'il dit là est intéressant à ce
qu'elle dit la f1 et c'est comme ça
qu'on construit moi j'ai envie de cette
construction là pour la martinique elle
en a besoin
bilan de la rentrée pour vous un bilan
positif plutôt il ya quelques chantiers
qui pose problème
oui mitigé un bilan mitigé moi cette
réforme des lycées elle a été trop
brusquement appliquée on a des
problématiques que comme maintenant
qu'on va comme d'habitude on aime
séparer on va rejeter sur la cité
hammouchi martin transports alors que
moi je n'en prends aucune légitimité
il ya un an jour pour jour en octobre
j'avais alerté monsieur le recteur sur
cette réforme et je lui avait dit
attention les spécialités les transports
entre les établissements sur le temps
scolaire c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas mise en place par martin transports
il faudra faire des appels d'offres il
faudra faire des revenants et monsieur
le président d'un martin transport n'ira
pas en prison pour monsieur tracteur
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est que
nous avons reçues même pas moi le markin
transports j'ai transféré le dos le
dossier marking transport et donc nous
avons reçu très tardivement
l'organisation du spécialité dans les
dents et lycées aujourd'hui les parents
sont en demande ils disent qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour que martine transport
nous fait passer une série transport là
c'est pas du dehors de la faute de leurs
c'était un nid de martine transports je
dirais pas que c'est la faute du
rectorat mais en tout cas cette
impréparation fait que nos enfants vont
en pâtir
et malheureusement nous avons des délais
contraints nous devons passer en conseil
d'administration
et ça
va attendre merci si le verset soutane
c'est terminé bonne journée à l'écouté
de nos programmes est assez à vous